The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right.
Welcome back to 6890.
Today we start a series of
lectures on satisfiability.
We saw a little bit
about satisfiability
in the first lecture.
Now we're going to do it right,
and do it more intensely,
and see a lot of examples.
Today we'll just
see a few examples
of using SAT to prevent
NP-completeness or NP-hardness.
But over the next lecture or two
we will see many more examples.
And SAT is really the
most common problem
that everyone uses
to prove NP-hardness.
So this is the moment you've
all been waiting for, I suppose.
This is one of the
motivations for organizing
this whole class, so we
can tell you all about SAT,
it's many variations, so
you get to learn them all,
and then see lots
of different ways
you can SAT to
represent your problems.
So without further
ado, let's get started.
Today I'm going to give you
a whole bunch of problems
and definitions, and then we
will do reductions afterwards.
So there's going to be
a lot of problems here.
You probably will have
trouble remembering them all,
there are so many.
But in particular,
the notes serve
as a useful reference,
like, here's
all the versions you
might care about--
here's which ones are
hard, which ones are easy.
So with that in mind,
get ready for the ride.
So the original SAT
problem is you're
given a Boolean formula, which
is like over the operators
AND, OR, and NOT.
And in case you look
at the literature,
usually AND is the wedge, OR
is the v, and NOT is the neg?
I don't know the
name of that symbol.
And it's over n
variables x1, x2, xn.
So usually, you're not
given true or false
so that you can construct
them by saying, x1 and not x1.
That's never true.
So that's false, for example.
And then you could
negate that and get true.
And the question is, can
you set the variables
to make the formula true?
So that's the general problem.
This is the very
first problem proved
to be NP-complete by
Cook and then by Levin.
So it's usually called
the Cook-Levin theorem,
the satisfiability
is NP-complete.
And I was looking at
the paper the other day.
It doesn't actually mention
the notion of NP in that paper.
I think that came later.
But the notion is there.
So I'll give you another
version of the same problem,
essentially, called circuit SAT.
This is a useful perspective
which we will see probably
not till next class.
But another way
to think about it.
Also makes it the
NP-completeness
a little bit more intuitive.
OK.
This is kind of the algebraic
way of thinking about things.
You have variables and
you write operators,
and you use parentheses
and that sort of thing.
But if you're more
graphically inclined,
you could imagine you
have your excise as wires,
they're connected to gates--
this is an and gate, this is
an or gate, this is a negation.
So you can imagine
something like this.
So you can, generally, copy
your data and do various things.
And then this is the output.
And so this is what you
might call the formula.
It is the AND of the
negation of the OR of x3
and the AND of x1 and x2.
And then, pop off, it's also
ANDed with this thing again.
So the one advantage
of circuit SAT
is you can reuse complex
computations, just
by copying the signal.
Normally, in a formula,
you'd have to copy and paste
that chunk of the formula.
So you could imagine this
lets you write formulas
slightly more efficiently.
I think it doesn't.
If you reuse things, you
can always write them
as a variable over here.
Question.
AUDIENCE: What about feedback?
PROFESSOR: Feedback
is forbidden.
So this should be a
directed acyclic graph.
Yeah.
Good question.
So it's an acyclic circuit.
That would be another problem,
which is harder than an NP.
So circuit SAT is
NP-complete when it's acyclic
and you can convert
between one and the other.
And it's a little
bit more intuitive
that you can write arbitrary
computations as a circuit.
And then this is a question
of whether you can--
the existence of some
setting of the AIs
is the same thing
as saying, is there
some set of guesses that
will lead me to a yes answer?
So that is intuitively
like NP and that's
roughly how you prove these
problems are NP-complete.
You write the computation--
the checking
computation-- to see
whether your certificate is a
valid certificate as a circuit
or as a formula.
And then the existential
quantifiers on the xi's let you
do all the guessing to
see whether they're--
and this is biased, right?
It's trying to find a true.
And that's exactly what NP does.
It's trying to find a true path
that ends up answering yes.
So yes and true
are symmetric here.
So that's the extent of
the complexity theory
we'll do today.
I'm going to give you
more versions of SAT.
Next one is CNF SAT.
CNF stands for
conjunctive normal form.
I hope you all know
prepositional logic.
Because we're going to
be doing a bunch today.
So ANDs are also
called conjunctions,
ORs are called disjunctions.
This is old terminology.
So conjunctive normal form
means that your formula
is an AND of clauses.
What's a clause?
Well a clause is going
to be an OR of literals.
What's a literal?
A literal is going
to be xi or not xi.
So these are variables.
So variables are
possible literals
and the negations of variables
and literals, and that's it.
And that is CNF SAT.
So it's a special case of SAT
where your formula happens
to have this picture.
And in general, you can
convert arbitrary formulas
into conjunctive normal form.
It's a normal form, meaning
it's essentially unique.
A minimal CNF formula is unique.
So there's a known
transformation
to do that, polynomial time.
That's how you
prove this is hard.
Another view in this picture.
We'll use CNF SAT a lot, usually
in even more specialized form.
But already, one useful view--
which we saw a little bit
in lecture one, we'll
see it again today--
is you can view such an
input as a bipartite graph.
You have, let's say,
variables on the one side
and clauses on the other side.
And then you have two types
of connections, a clause--
in general, a clause is
going to have degree three.
And let's say the
dashed edges are negated
and the solid edges
are not negated.
So this is a clause that
involves x1 or x2 or not x3.
And in general, each
of these clauses
is going to involve some
number of variables over here.
I said three, but I haven't
actually gotten to three yet.
That is 3SAT.
So the most common
form of CNF SAT we use
is called 3SAT, where it's CNF
SAT in the special case where
the clause is an
or three literals.
And you can assume it's
exactly three or at most three.
So that's like saying the
degree of each of the clause
notes here is exactly three.
And that's the
problem with it we
used for proving Super
Mario Brothers was
hard in the first lecture.
So in my notes I have
things nicely indented.
So we had CNF SAT, which
is a special case of SAT,
and then 3SAT, which is a
special case of CNF SAT.
A special case of 3SAT that's
also hard is called 3SAT-5.
I don't know that this
is super standard,
but I found at least one
paper that gives it this name.
This says that each
variable occurs in less than
or equal to five clauses, either
in it's positive or negated
form.
So this is sometimes called
max five occurrence 3-SAT.
And I think you can even make
them exactly five occurrances
if you want.
But, at most, five occurrances
is usually what you want.
Question.
AUDIENCE: Is that
tight as 3SAT-4 NP?
PROFESSOR: That's
a good question.
3SAT-4?
I don't know.
I would guess it's tight.
Because there are a lot of
people that mention five,
but I haven't seen a mention
that four is polynomial.
All right?
So we should figure that out.
Other questions?
Or it's probably the same one.
All right.
Here's another
special case of 3SAT.
Monotone 3SAT.
This is where each clause is
all positive or all negative.
So of course, if every
clause is all positive,
then you could set all
the variables to true
and you'll satisfy.
If all the classes are negative,
you set all the variables
to false and you satisfy.
But if half the clauses
are all positive,
half the clauses are all
negative, then that's hard.
That's called monotone 3SAT.
I've actually not
seen this used,
but I imagine it is helpful
in a few situations.
This is definitely
the most common.
Almost every proof
starts with 3SAT.
But it's really good to
know all the extra things
you can assume about your 3SAT
problem and it still be hard.
I have more hard versions,
but before we get there
I'm going to tell you
about some easy versions.
And question.
AUDIENCE: Is monotone 3SAT-5?
PROFESSOR: Another
good question.
Monotone 3SAT-5, is
that NP complete?
I don't know.
Partly these were done
at different times.
Monotone 3SAT is mentioned
in Garey and Johnson
as done in 1978, presumably for
a particular hardness proof.
3SAT-5 is probably
a very old idea.
Probably this idea of
reducing occurances
goes to some logic thing.
But the earliest reference
I found was 1998,
and most people had forgotten
about monotone 3SAT by then.
So it probably just
hasn't been considered,
but it might be easy.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: The construction
to limit to five variables--
should I believe work with the
monotone construction as well?
PROFESSOR: OK.
Conjecture.
Yes, it's hard.
OK.
But stay tuned for
a certain answer.
So let me tell you
some polynomial time
versions of SAT.
The three is tight if you
have a clause being an
or of two literals,
but otherwise
they're just like 3SAT--
or just like CNF SAT, I guess--
then this is polynomial time.
And let me give you
a rough sketch why.
So if you have an
or of two literals,
that's something like x or y.
And the little bit of
propositional logic
you should know is the meaning
of, let's say, a implies b.
Saying this should hold--
and a and b are
either true or false--
is the same as
saying not a or b.
Because if a is false, then the
implication tells you nothing.
If a is true, then it better
be the case that b is true.
So either a is
false, in which case
you don't worry about
something, or a is true,
and then b better
be true, as well.
So these are the same--
maybe write triple
equals, for these are
equivalent logical statements.
So we can apply
that here and say
x or y is the same thing
as not x implies y,
or not y implies x.
It's symmetric.
But this is now just
a simple implication.
If we ever set x to be
false, then y must be true.
And every clause
can be converted
into such an implication.
You can build a graph of
all such implications.
And then, turns out, to
solve 2SAT, you can just
pick your favorite variable,
xi, set it to true,
follow all implications,
see whether you
get a contradiction.
If you don't, then
the claim is there
is a satisfying assignment
where xi equals true.
So you can try that
with xi true, xi false.
If there's any hope,
then one of them
should say no contradiction.
Then just run with that.
And you can prove by induction
that won't get stuck.
It won't make any
impossible assignments,
unless there was no
assignment to begin with.
So that's why 2SAT is easy
and one of the situations
you should be careful about.
On the other hand,
MAX 2SAT is hard.
So MAX 2SAT is you're
given a 2SAT formula--
you're given a 2CNF formula--
and normally, we ask for an
assignment to the variables
that satisfies all the
clauses, but if you just
want to satisfy k of them--
so satisfy k of the clauses.
So usually you
want to maximize k,
but let's say, for a decision
problem, I'll give you k
and I want to know, can you
satisfy k of the clauses?
That problem is NP hard.
So that can be useful.
If you can only
represent 2SAT clauses,
but you can somehow get
a maximization thing in,
then you're golden again.
But 2SAT alone is not enough.
There are some other
easy-to-solve versions.
This is essentially a
generalization of 2SAT
is Horn SAT.
It's maybe a little
bit more surprising
the first time you see it.
Again, it's a special
case of CNF SAT, which
you can tell by my indentation.
Each clause has at most
one negative literal.
So that means a clause is
going to look something like--
has one negative?
Sorry.
Horn is the other way around.
We will get-- that
problem is also solvable.
But the one that's
called Horn SAT is--
there's at most one
positive literal.
So that means
you're form is going
to look something like not
x or not y are not z or w.
So there's one positive.
The rest are all negated.
And we can do some more
prepositional logic.
So use De Morgan's theorem.
This is the same thing as
the negation of the AND.
OK?
And then we can apply
this helpful rule.
And say this is the same thing
as if x and y and z are true,
then w better be true.
And so you can use essentially
the same algorithm that
you're--
I mean, slightly
harder to check.
If all three of these
things are true,
then this one better be true.
But it's always a guarantee.
You know this thing must happen.
Just like in 2-SAT, if x
happened to be set to false,
then you know y must be true.
So you can just follow
these implication chains.
If you get a contradiction,
you know you're in trouble.
If you don't get
a contradiction,
again, you can
prove by induction
that all will be well.
And so you just
make sure every time
you assign a variable you
don't get a contradiction
and you can satisfy
any Horn formula.
So that's cool.
So I didn't write
it on the board,
but this is
polynomially solvable.
There's a symmetric version,
which is called Dual Horn SAT.
So this is the same thing, but
at most one negative literal
in each clause.
And this is also solvable
in polynomial time
because you can just negate all
the variables in your formula.
And then when you
get an answer, you
can negate all the
variables again
to get the solution to
the original problem.
So because you can
solve Horn SAT,
you can solve Dual Horn SAT.
Cool.
One more bad case I'll
mention now is DNF SAT.
You might say, well, why do
we make things ANDs of ORs?
What about ORs of ANDs?
So DNF is disjunctive
normal form,
meaning the disjunctions
are on the outside.
So the formula is an AND of OR--
sorry.
AUDIENCE: It's an OR of ANDs.
PROFESSOR: Other way.
OR of ANDs of literals.
We use some shorthand,
not-defined clauses
here because we don't
really use this problem.
Because it's polynomial time.
Why is it polynomial time?
AUDIENCE: You can just
evaluate one of the ANDs.
PROFESSOR: Just evaluate
one of the ANDs.
If you--
AUDIENCE: If it's true.
PROFESSOR: Right.
It's true if any one
of these is possible.
So you can just check for
obvious contradictions, like xi
and not xi.
If that happens, then
that cause is impossible.
Throw it away.
If any clause has no
internal contradictions,
then just satisfy the clause.
OK?
It's basically-- the answer is
yes whenever there is a clause.
It could be of the empty
formula, no clauses.
So writing-- you can also
write any formula into DNF.
It's like an enumeration of
all the true possibilities.
But it takes exponential
time to do so.
So it's a funny asymmetry
between AND and OR.
That's life.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I just want
to say, for Horn SAT,
even if you don't have
Horn SAT or Dual Horn SAT,
you might have a formula
where some renaming--
not necessarily all
of the literals--
but renaming just
some of the literals
will put it in Horn SAT.
And that's also in--
PROFESSOR: Oh.
Just negating some of them.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Like, each time a
variable occurs,
you have to negate all the
instances of that variable.
But these are called
renamable Horn formulas.
And it's also-- finding the
renaming is linear time.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So some kind of renamable Horn.
And by renaming, you just
mean negating, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
The term used in the
literature is renamable Horn.
PROFESSOR: There exists
a negation of, let's say,
some subset of the
variable's x such that Horn.
OK?
That's the very concise version.
So you get to choose some of the
variables to negate and make it
a Horn clause that's
also polynomial time.
Cool.
Thank you.
You might be wondering
at this point, how much--
I mean, do I have to
remember all of these?
And sometimes the answer is yes.
But there is actually
a dichotomy theorem
that will tell you
which versions of SAT
are polynomial time and
which versions are NP hard,
and we'll cover that
in one more page.
But I'm-- well, all of these
are involved in the statement
of that dichotomy.
Not quite all, but most of them.
So it's not exactly a shortcut.
I would say a lot of
the time, the problem
you're working with
does not naturally
map onto ANDs and ORs.
It sort of involves bits of
some sort-- there's a 0 and a 1
notion-- but they may not really
correspond to logical notions
of true or false.
And the operations
you can do on them
may not correspond to AND or
OR, or anything nice like that.
So the next two versions
of SAT are in that spirit.
So this is usually, these
days, called 1-in3 SAT,
but originally it was
called exactly-1 3SAT.
So this is going to be a little
bit weirder to write down,
but like CNF SAT, the formula is
the end of a bunch of clauses.
So that part's the same.
But now we're going
to make a clause
to be a relation on
three variables, which
is that exactly one of, let's
say, xi, xj, and xk is true.
So this means it could be
true-false-false, xi is true,
but the other two are false,
it could be xj is true,
the other two are false, or
it could be that xk is true
and the other two are false.
But those are the only
happy assignments.
Question.
AUDIENCE: Is it exactly one
of three variables or three
literals?
PROFESSOR: Good question.
The original statement
is its variables,
so that's how I wrote it.
This is usually called monotone.
These days it's usually
called monotone 1-in-3SAT.
I don't know how
usually exactly.
Sometimes it's called
all positive 1-in-3SAT.
So let's say literals
equal variables.
You could, of course,
if you want, consider
a more general version where
you can have negations.
But you don't need
to, so why bother.
That fact is usually
forgotten in most proofs.
So you'll see in the
literature a reduction
from 1-in-3SAT with
negations, and they
have a negation gadget.
It's like, you don't need
to have a negation gadget.
So why not skip it?
But there you go.
Now I'll just mention
I'm not a fan of the word
monotone here because here
we have monotone to mean
all positive or all negative.
Here we mean all positive.
Not ideal reuse of terminology.
I think that's why sometimes
this is all positive 1-in-3SAT.
Anyway, it's a bit of a mess.
But that is the state
of the literature.
So you get it all.
All right.
Here's another problem.
Monotone not-exactly-1 3SAT.
I should not have
any suspense here.
This is NP.
OK?
This is NP-complete.
This is also NP-complete.
But not-exactly-1
3SAT is polynomial.
So I think you
know what it means.
A clause specifies that-- again,
we take an and of clauses.
And we want zero, two, or three
of three variables are true.
In other words, exactly
one of them is false.
No.
I don't mean that.
Exactly one of them being
false would be 1-in-3SAT again,
just by negating
everything, which we're
allowed to do if we want to.
But this is different.
This is saying, it could
be everything's false,
or it could be one
thing is false,
or it could be zero
things are false.
But not two things are false.
OK?
This turns out to be polynomial.
And do I have--
oh.
There's one funny
thing here, which
is if all your clauses
look like this,
you can set all your
variables to false.
So this is sort of
a trivial problem.
But to make it more
interesting, you
can say x1 equals true,
just to get you started.
So there's no
trivial solution then
and it still turns
out this is easy.
Because if you think
about this long enough,
as I did yesterday, this
will look something like--
if you have three variables,
either they're all false--
then fine--
or if one of them is
true, then you better
have another one true.
That's a way of saying if
there's at least one of them,
there better be at least two.
That's what we want.
This has to be true for
all shifts of i, j, k.
So for each of i, j, k,
if one of them is true,
you want to imply
the OR of the other.
And this is the same
as NOT xi or xj or xk.
Don't need the
parentheses because it's
associative communicative.
And that is a dual horn clause.
And that's why
this is polynomial.
Question.
AUDIENCE: I think I'm
confused about the definition.
Why can't they just
all be true then?
PROFESSOR: Good question.
Let's say x2 is false.
I should double check.
I don't remember that in the
statement of the problem.
We do not allow negations here.
Once you allow negations,
this trick won't work.
But if these appear
all in positive form,
then we can convert
into the single negative
and get dual horn.
Question.
AUDIENCE: Are you allowed to
mix the zero, two, and threes?
Or does it have to be all
the clauses have to be--
PROFESSOR: All
causes look like--
all clauses say, zero, two, or
three of these three variables
must be true.
You can't have a clause that
says zero of these are true
and two of these are true.
AUDIENCE: No.
But if you have two of
these clauses that give you
all those choices,
can you choose
one to be zero and then
have another one be two,
or whatever.
PROFESSOR: For each clause,
it's an independent choice
whether you have zero, two, or
three of the variables true.
Yeah.
So this OR is local
to the clause.
Other questions?
So it's still an
AND of things that--
it's just we have
a weirder relation.
Instead of just taking the OR
of a bunch of things, which
would be saying at least
one of them is true,
now we allow zero or two or
three of them to be true.
OK.
One more version,
then we'll get to--
well, one and a
half more versions--
then we'll get to the
dichotomy theorem.
So x1 is Not-All-Equal-3SAT.
I feel like that's
about all I need
to write down, other than the
fact that it is NP-complete.
But just in case,
what this means is
a clause is something
like Not-All-Equal
of three variables again.
And this is what I'm defining
is going to be the monotone
Not-All-Equal-3SAT--
which is also hard--
where these are variables,
not just literals.
So no negations in monotone
Not-All-Equal-3SAT.
Again, the original
proof already
had monotonicity in there, so
there's no work to be done.
Cool.
So not all equal just
means that they're not
all the same values.
So that means not all
true and not all false.
Not TTT and not FFF.
I really like this
version of 3SAT
because it's
completely symmetric
between true and false.
I mean, not at the clause level.
Every clause has
to be satisfied.
Those are ANDed together
in the logical level.
But the xi's are
treated completely
symmetrically between
true and false.
You could just call
them red and blue.
There's no reason to think
one is true one is false.
You just can't have them all be
the same color within a clause.
OK.
So you could think of it as
a problem on hypergraphs.
Three uniform hypergraphs,
you have all these triples
of things.
You just want them to not
all be colored the same.
So it means two of one, one
of the other two trues and one
false, two reds and one
blue, two falses, one true.
They're all this--
those are all good cases
and these are the bad cases.
Cool.
AUDIENCE: So this is
one or two in 3SAT?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
You can think of this
exactly one or two
in 3SAT, if you want to
phrase it in this style.
OK.
So ideally, you should
remember all of these.
But I'll tell you the
most important ones
are regular 3SAT--
that's at least one of
each thing is true--
exactly 1 3SAT, or 1-in-3SAT--
where exactly one of the things
is true, and adding more things
breaks it--
and Not-All-Equal-3SAT.
Those are the three
important ones
to know from a lower
bounds perspective.
These others are
to, like, be careful
that you don't fall into
one of these things that
is polynomial.
So occasionally MAX
2SAT is the one other
that would be useful here.
But remember these guys.
They're super handy.
Because what will happen when
you're proving hardness is you
fool around and
you try to find--
you build a gadget
that has two truths--
two possible ways to satisfy it.
Call one red and one blue
or one true and one false.
And then you try different
ways to combine three of them.
And you're trying to get--
you need some other
things-- but you're
trying to get clause gadgets.
Trying to get them to--
when you combine three
wires into a little gadget,
you want them to be
constrained somehow.
That in order to be
globally OK, something
must hold locally at
those three things.
And it might end up being
a Not-All-Equal constraint,
it might end up being
an exactly 1 constraint,
or it might end up
being a 3SAT constraint.
With some negations
to make it happy,
it should be one of
those to be hard.
If you fall into something like
this, then that's not good.
Question.
AUDIENCE: So let's say, since
this Not-All-Equal thing--
let's say you call
it red and blue.
What if you add green?
Then would there be--
would Not-All-Equal
3SAT be NP-hard,
or would you need
4SAT or something?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So what about ternary truth?
I-- there might be a
problem on that in the PSET.
But in general, you would
have to go through the work
to check which problems.
I think those are
pretty uncommon.
So usually what you do is
if you have a gadget that
can be solved not two
ways, but four ways,
is you call two of them
true and two of them false
and hope they behave
more or less identically.
So that's the most common
answer, practically,
to what we do.
But it certainly is plausible
with three different values.
Some of these are
going to be hard
but I don't know which ones.
Hopefully all them, but
you have to be careful.
And definitely the next theorem
I'm going to talk about--
the dichotomy theorem--
would get more complicated
with three colors.
Nice question.
So let's do Schaefer's
Dichotomy Theorem.
This is about which versions
of SAT are polynomial
and which versions
are NP-complete.
With the right set up, every
problem you can think of
is either polynomial
or NP-complete.
There's no things in between.
These are called
NP-intermediate problems.
So it's always going to be
one extreme or the other,
as I'm about to set it up.
And this theorem is by Schaefer.
And in the very
same paper he proves
Not-All-Equal 3SAT and
1-in-3SAT are hard.
Those are the original proofs.
So it's a great paper.
I have looked at it many times.
It's from 1978.
So long time ago.
But still quite readable.
So I don't know how much-- all
the last problems we've stated
have this property, but
I'll make it explicit again.
That's your formula is going
to be an AND of clauses.
And now we're going to allow
general kinds of clauses.
A clause is just going
to be any relation
on some number of variables.
So there won't be any notion
of literal here because you
can put that in the relation.
I'll call this a general
clause and say relation
on some variables.
So relation is something--
I give you a set of truth
values for those variables
and we'll say yes or no.
That's valid or it's invalid.
You can think of a
relation as the set
of all assignments, their
variables, and make it true.
But you don't have to
specify that, per se.
You just sort of
know what it is.
OK.
So I mean, in
particular, it could
be the OR of three
variables, then we get 3SAT.
Or it could be the Not-All-Equal
constraint on three variables,
then it's Not-All-Equal
3SAT, and so on.
OK.
We are going to--
so I guess, sorry.
The relationship should be given
to you as a Boolean formula.
So it could be an OR, or
you can write 1-in-3SAT
as a Boolean formula.
It's just little tedious.
You could say, well it could
be this, or it could be this,
or it could be this.
In general, I'm going
to assume that they're
given to you in CNF form.
Sorry, that's redundant.
CNF has form in it.
Because any formula
can be made into CNF.
So now CNF is an
AND of ORs, so this
is going to be an AND of what
we might normally call clauses,
but we're already
in a clause, so I'm
going to call this subclauses.
Starting to sound like legalese.
I made up this word.
It's not in the literature.
So in general, your formula
is an AND of clauses,
each one is your
sum relation, which
we're going to think of
as an AND of subclauses.
Of course, it's really just
an AND of all the things.
But this is trying
to be general.
Because we're going to have
constraints in the clauses,
in particular.
So then claim is SAT--
on these types of formulas--
so here's the
difference, I guess.
To define the problem, you
specify what kind of relations
that you allow.
So in 3SAT, we say, OK,
so OR of three things.
In CNF SAT, it's an OR
of k things for any k.
In Not-All-Equal 3SAT, it's
not all equal of three things,
and so on.
So we give that up front and
then the decision problem
is well, I have
n variables and I
can combine them with these
clauses however I want.
So we need some kind
of infinity, right?
If I gave you a
specific problem,
then it's not going
to be NP-hard.
Like, with these 10
variables, that's
never going to be interesting.
So I give you the notion
of what causes are allowed,
what relations are
permitted, and then I
want to consider the class
of all possible formulas you
can build with
clauses of that type.
So you can think of this as
really more of a clause type,
like Not-All-Equal,
just to be precise here.
And then we get
a version of SAT.
And it's going to be polynomial
if one of four cases happen.
At least one.
Any one of these
will make it easy.
We have seen almost
all of these.
So first one is setting
all variables true
satisfies the formula.
Well not just the formula,
but all formulas of this type.
Or all variables false
satisfies all clauses.
OK.
This is a statement over all
formulas with this clause type,
right?
So, a statement about
the clause types.
And it's one of the issues we
were having with not exactly
1 3SAT, because there the
clause type allowed everything
to be false and it also
had everything to be true,
so it was doubly bad.
But of course is if
you have clauses where
this is true for all the--
you could allow different
types of clauses.
You could have Not-All-Equal
plus 1-in-3SAT, that
will also be hard, of course.
But if all of your clauses have
this property, then of course,
you just globally set the
variables and you're done.
OK.
That was the first case.
All right.
So the next one is that
it could be the subclauses
are all Horn, or all dual Horn.
So those are two happy
cases we saw before.
I mean, we can think
of the overall problem
as an AND of the clauses,
which are ANDs of subclauses,
so if everything is a
Horn or dual Horn thing,
then we're happy.
And next case is the
relations are all 2-CNF.
So this would be the 2SAT case.
If all the relations you're
working with are in 2-CNF,
then when we AND them together,
you still have a 2-CNF formula,
so you can solve it by 2SAT.
So these are all
things we've seen.
There's one more
case we haven't seen.
Is there a question?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Isn't 2SAT just a
subcase of the Horn and dual
Horn thing?
Because you're always
going to have--
PROFESSOR: It's true.
2SAT is a special case of Horn.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: You could have
one with two positives
and another one
with two negatives.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, that's true.
Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Ah,
right, right, right.
So I see.
So 2-CNF, some of the
clauses are going to be Horn
and some of them are
dual Horn, I think.
So it doesn't fall into
this because it's not
all one or the other.
In general, those
combinations are bad.
But 2SAT is always OK.
Good question.
OK Last case is
some linear algebra.
This is one other
easy case of SAT
which doesn't come
up very often,
so I didn't write it
as a separate one.
So imagine equations like this.
I take some number variables,
I x OR them together and I say,
that should be 0, or similar
thing, I set it equal to 1.
Those are what I would call
linear equation over Zmod2.
Because in Zmod2-- the finite
field in two elements--
addition becomes x OR and
there's no multiplication here
because it's a linear system.
So we can solve these things
because z2 is a finite field.
We can use Gaussian
elimination if-- even
if I have a whole bunch
of these equations,
I can solve them all using
Gaussian elimination.
Or determine that
they're unsolvable.
So that's another easy case
for SAT to be careful about.
And the theorem is if you
have one of these situations--
so you can't mix these.
If you have one
clause of this type
and another clause of this type,
your problem will be NP-hard.
So in general, you say,
otherwise SAT is NP-hard.
I guess it will
actually be NP-complete
here, the way we've set it up.
Well, assuming the
relations are checkable.
So these are the only cases.
This is an easy case,
this is an easy case,
this is an easy case.
It could be that multiple
of these things are true.
Maybe your 2CNF
and your all Horn.
That will also be
polynomial, of course.
But if none of these
individually hold,
then your problem is NP-hard.
Question.
AUDIENCE: So how
does this generalize
from non-Boolean fields?
I'm sure the last one
is also still true.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So we can go back to your
question about three colors,
and the answer is I don't know.
As far as I know, there's
no theorem of that type.
But there might be one.
It's been 30 years.
So it wouldn't be surprising.
Certainly, you can-- some
of these positive results
will generalize.
But I think even this one
would be a little tricky.
AUDIENCE: So MAX 2SAT
doesn't fall in this?
PROFESSOR: Right.
So here the goal is always to
satisfy all of the clauses.
It's always the AND
of all the clauses.
You could imagine a
MAX 2SAT-like theorem.
My guess is most
problems will be hard.
But as far as I know,
there's no such theorem.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is there any way
to understand this theorem
as making a geometric statement
about the relation being convex
and hypercube or something?
Like, is there any
sort of convexity
property encoded in this?
PROFESSOR: I don't know.
I would guess no.
I know there is a
more modern take
on this that is more algebraic.
So it's more like, if you
start with these things
and you can build
up in this way,
anything you can
build up in this way
are the polynomial
solvable versions of SAT.
Anything you can't build
up in this way is NP-hard.
So if you're interested in
that, check the Wikipedia page
for Schaefer's
Dichotomy Theorem.
But I don't think there's
a geometric interpretation.
This one, obviously, has a
geometric interpretation.
But I think the others
not, would be my guess.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So does
this say something
about the complexity of
recognizing the clauses if you
interpret them as a language?
PROFESSOR: If I give
you the formula that
specifies the types
of clauses, can you
determine whether any
of these is the case.
I would guess yes, but I
don't know of such a theorem.
So another good question.
So many questions
to think about here.
It's definitely not
explicitly mentioned,
that I saw, in the
Schaefer paper.
But it's been around for
a while so people may
have thought about that more.
It definitely can
be a little tricky
to check which things are
of this type, practically.
So it would be nice if
there was an algorithm.
I would say-- so again,
practically speaking,
there was one hardness proof I
was trying to generate gadgets
computationally.
So just enumerate
all possible gadgets
of a certain size
for my problem,
and then see what formula
they were representing.
And then we would take that
formula, do a Karnaugh map--
if you've ever done
digital logic stuff--
and then from that, you
get a nice, minimal form.
And then we would--
usually we could
just look at the map
and say, oh, that's
just equals, or that's
not equals or something.
We were hoping for-- we
were dreaming for-- one
of these things or 3SAT.
We never got the
gadget we wanted.
So I think, with a Karnaugh
map, you could do this.
But that's exponential time.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: So I
don't know for sure.
I should probably check
the algebraic view.
That might--
AUDIENCE: That's a
clever approach though.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: To do things
computationally.
PROFESSOR: It's
definitely helpful.
Because of course,
computationally, you
can only look at small gadgets.
But hopefully there is a small
gadget and then a nice proof.
So why do the hard work of
generating them yourself when
the computer could
do it for you?
It doesn't work
for all problems.
Your problems need to
be locally isolatable.
To not worry about
the big picture.
Other questions?
Cool.
Well that's all the versions
of SAT you need to know.
Because here we have the
universality theorem.
There will be another
one or two that we
bump into but these are the
things you should all know.
It's really helpful
when doing a proof
to not have to worry about
which version 3SAT you even
are going to use, and just know
that these are all out here.
So that when you find a gadget
that happens to match one,
and then you say,
oh, well I meant
to do a reduction from
Not-All-Equal 3SAT.
That's why I wanted
to tell you all these,
although I know it's a lot
to take in all at once.
Let's do some
reductions, finally.
NP hardcore time.
So the first one, I had
actually never seen before,
but it's in Schaefer's paper.
So I thought it'd
be fun to cover.
Here's a problem,
which is NP-hard,
and we will actually
prove this one NP-hard.
2-colorable perfect matching.
Let's say you're given a
planar 3-regular graph,
every vertex has degree 3.
And what you'd like to do is
2-color the vertices, a red
and blue, such that every
vertex has exactly one
neighbor of the same color.
OK.
So if you look at a vertex and
it has three neighbors, then--
let's say we color
this guy red, there
should be exactly one
neighbor that's red.
And so you can think of
this edge as being red,
and then the red edges will
form a perfect matching
in the graph.
Every vertex will
be [? instant to ?]
exactly one edge.
So that's the 2-colorable
perfect matching.
It's kind of-- well, sorry.
The red edges form
perfect matching
on the red nodes,
and the black--
or the white edges, I guess--
form a perfect matching
on the white nodes,
black nodes, whatever.
So it's like two
perfect matchings,
one in each color class.
So this is a nice problem.
You can think of it
as SAT, in a sense.
It's, again, just a local
constraint on the notes.
And so you can think of this
as being a clause involving
those four guys.
I think, unless I
did something wrong,
you can think of it
as 2SAT and 4SAT,
or a special version
of 2SAT and 4SAT.
Because-- is that right?
Yeah.
So let's say red is true.
So what we're saying
is if this guy is true,
among these four nodes
there should be exactly one
other one that is red.
On the other hand,
if this is black,
there should be exactly
one of them that is black.
And so the other
two should be red.
So in all cases, it's exactly
two and four of them are red.
And it's symmetric between red
and black, so that seems good.
So this is a special
case of 2SAT and 4SAT.
In case you were wondering
whether 2SAT and 4SAT is hard,
here it is.
And I have the original
reduction by Schaefer here.
Do I have any notes?
No, that would be too easy.
So here's a gadget and
here's another gadget,
and then they're
pasted together.
And I should mention--
so Schaefer claims that if you
have a planar 3-regular graph,
this problem is hard.
But he doesn't prove it.
He just proves it
for general graphs,
so I'm only going to prove
it for general graphs.
Maybe we can think about
planar 3-regular case,
but not right here.
So this will just make a graph
instance to that problem.
So this gadget,
this is a k4 on--
and we're only
distinguishing x, y, and z.
And it has to form--
there's going to be one red
edge and one black edge.
So maybe like this,
and like this.
Or like this, or like this.
It's going to be a rotation
of one of those assignments.
So I believe the
claim is x, y, and z,
just looking at
those three vertices,
should be not-all-equal.
OK?
If two of them are
red, by symmetry--
there's lots of
rotational symmetry
here-- so maybe two of them
are red and one is black.
Then this guy can be set
black and you're happy.
It's actually forced for
that guy to be black.
If two of them are black,
then these two must be red.
And if all three of these
are black, you're toast.
Because you should
have two of each.
And if all three of them
are red, you're in trouble.
So this is a not-all-equal
clause gadget for this problem.
So we're going to reduce
from Not-All-Equal 3SAT
to 2-colorable perfect matching.
So we're representing a
Not-All-Equal clause like this.
And now what we need is the
ability to copy data, right?
So these are three variables
that-- at the moment, yeah,
they can be red or blue.
But what we need
is that the same xi
can appear in multiple clauses.
Because we have a
bipartite graph.
If every variable appeared
in only in one clause,
the problem would
be really easy.
So that's what this gadget does.
The claim is this
gadget copies a value.
And this, I think, requires--
so it says that these two
guys must have the same color.
And so what you do
is you just have--
for each Not-All-Equal
clause-- you
have one of these
Not-All-Equal gadgets.
And then whenever you
have two variables
that are supposed to be the
same thing here, it's x and x.
In our terminology, xi and xi.
Then you're just going to
connect them with this gadget.
And that will force
them to be equal.
Or over here we have y and y.
So r here is Not-All-Equal.
In our terminology, it'd
be NAE, xxy, and yzu.
This would represent
that formula.
So the thing to check, which
I will leave as an exercise,
because it seems--
at least, I couldn't find
a clean way to do it.
It seems a little bit tedious.
That this forces equality
between the two ends,
not providing any
other constraints.
So that was a simple proof.
One of few simple proofs.
Still some cases to check.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Wait, you said
those general graphs,
they don't [? tap in? ?]
PROFESSOR: Right.
This is general graphs.
So you might say, what about
planar 3-regular graphs?
Planar Not-All-Equal 3SAT--
when this graph is planar--
when the bipartite graph
is planar-- it's actually
easy to solve, polynomial.
So you can't reduce from
planar Not-All-Equal 3SAT
because it's easy.
But I would guess that
in this situation--
and we just proved this is
a more general problem than
Not-All-Equal 3SAT--
what we would need at this
point is a crossover gadget.
So that when-- and this
thing is going to end up with
crossings--
if there's a gadget
that just communicates
the information
across the crossover,
without any other
constraints, then we
can just plug that in and
get rid of all crossings.
Then we have a planar graph
and that would prove this part.
And then the other part is that
we have high degree nodes here.
And so I'm guessing
Schaefer had in
mind the gadget that
takes a high degree node
and splits it up into lots of
little lower degree nodes--
degree 3 nodes-- that
simulates the same effect.
But I don't know either gadget.
But that would be
my guess on how to--
that would be the
obvious approach of how
to proceed to get that theorem.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: The other
gadget is just
[? 1b ?] split into
degree 3 copies connected
by that gadget.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Good.
One gadget down.
Now we just need a crossover.
Other questions?
All right.
I want to talk about two
families of problems--
a proof hardness for two
families of problems-- next.
One is called pushing blocks.
These come up in lots of
different video games.
One of the first, I
think, is called Sokoban.
This goes back to 1984 and this
is, I believe, the original CGA
graphics for Sokoban.
And so you may have
played Sokoban.
I think it's in Emacs.
It's all over the place.
Tons of implementations on it.
You are at a warehouseman, that
is what sokoban means literally
in Japanese.
And you have these boxes.
They're all one by one boxes.
You are one by one.
There are some bricks
which cannot be moved.
You have some target
locations and your poor job
is to move all these boxes
into the target locations.
Or rather, every
target location must
be covered by exactly one box.
Boxes can overlap each
other, you can push a box,
but you can only
push one at a time
because you're not that strong.
So you could not, for
example, push left here.
But in general, your inputs
are up, down, left, and right.
Up, up, down, down,
left, right, left, right.
And you can only push
one block at a time.
So if you push a
block into a corner,
it's never going to move again.
So often you have to hit reset.
There's a lot of
ways to get stuck.
But this is a solvable instance.
I think it's level five
in the original game.
So this got started a
huge family of problems.
There are tons of
other video games
that have pushing
blocks problems.
This is one, in Legend of
Zelda: Minish Cap, which I think
is a Gameboy Advance game.
It's been a while since
I played this one.
But here is a level
where you have--
it's in perspective
a little bit,
but this is really a 2D problem.
Everything is one by one.
Believe me.
You have one by one blocks.
You're on ice.
So if you ever push a
block, it will slide off
to infinity unless it hits
something else, like a block.
And your goal is to
get a block here.
OK?
Anyone see how to do it?
AUDIENCE: It's like
Ricochet Robots.
AUDIENCE: Can you
walk without sliding?
PROFESSOR: It's a lot
like Ricochet Robots.
Yeah.
You can walk wherever you want.
There is no block.
So there's lots of free
space in this case.
So you can push this guy down
and then push it over and then
push it up.
It's actually not that hard.
At some point I was
thinking, well maybe
I should stack up three
here so it ends up-- but no.
It's just three pushes
and you're done.
And if you watch the YouTube
video that's linked from this,
you'll see him spend
like 30 minutes
until he finds the
right solution.
In the game, it's frustrating
because once you push them off,
they disappear and you have
to leave and come back.
Anyway.
So out of all these games,
we've defined a bunch of models.
Here's one aspect of the model.
So we have the
fixed blocks, which
are in red, the movable
blocks, which are in cyan here,
and the robot is blue.
Everything's one by one.
And in one model, which we call
Push, when you push a block,
it moves one step.
That's the normal model.
And that's like Sokoban.
And I'll talk about
the two in a second.
In PushPush-- this is
like the on-ice version.
So you're not on ice.
You can still kind of
move and then kind of
counteract physics and
just move one step.
But the blocks, they'll just fly
off until they hit something.
So here, this block will
fly until it goes there.
In PushPushPush,
everything is so slippery
that if you hit a block and
it hits another block that's
movable, they will all
just keep going until they
hit an immovable block.
AUDIENCE: But you don't slip.
PROFESSOR: You still don't
slip in any of these models.
So there's another
version where you slip,
which has not been
considered so much.
Although Ricochet Robots
has been considered
and that's in that genre.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is there a model
where the block you first pushed
stops and transfers its
momentum to the other--
PROFESSOR: Oh, cool.
Yeah.
Conservation momentum.
So this one hits then
the next one goes.
That's probably--
AUDIENCE: PushStopPush.
PROFESSOR: PushStopPush.
I would guess that's also
hard because this ends up
being the same proof.
I'm guessing that works,
but we would need to check.
That's a good-- yeah.
The push-- push ricochet push.
OK.
One other thing here
is the number two.
You'll notice only
two blocks are moving.
And normally here, two is
the strength of the robot,
meaning if there are
up to two in a row,
you can push two blocks, but
once there are three in a row,
you can't push at all.
The idea here is the
same thing happens.
So they're just too heavy.
After you get up
to three of them,
then they'll stop sliding.
And same with PushPushPush.
AUDIENCE: So Sokoban
is actually Push-1.
PROFESSOR: Sokoban
is like Push-1.
It's a little bit
more complicated,
as illustrated in this table.
So Sokoban is here and you can
only push one block at a time.
There are fixed blocks.
And in general, the models
that have fixed blocks
are highlighted in pink here.
The slide thing is trying
to capture whether it just
moves one step or all the
way until it can't anymore.
That's the max.
And there's only a
couple of slide versions.
I haven't put PushPushPush
here because that
would be the only difference--
is what max means.
But everything else
you just move one step.
Then the other issue
is, what is the goal?
I mentioned in Sokoban you
have to cover every storage
space with a box.
That is the only problem with
that flavor, in this list
anyway.
All the ones that
are called Push--
the goal is just to get
the robot to a destination,
like in Mario or
Zelda or something.
So that's the difference
between Sokoban and Push-1.
Well Push-1-f, I suppose,
is pushing one thing
at a time with fixed blocks.
That's identical to Sokoban
except for this issue of what
the goal is.
Either just to get from s to t--
the robot-- or to
get all the blocks
into a particular configuration.
OK.
Well there are some
other things here.
We've talked about Push-k.
Push-star is when k is infinity.
So when you push, you can--
your arbitrary strength--
you can push as many blocks
in a row as you want.
PushPush-k, PushPush-star, then.
We've talked about f. f is
when you have fixed blocks.
Push-1-f, Push-k-f,
and Push-star-f.
And then there's one
other variation here
that's been considered,
which is the x.
This is when the path
that the robot takes
must not cross itself--
must not revisit a square.
This is-- there a
lot of video games
where after you leave a
square, that square disappears.
It falls down into the
abyss and so you're scared.
So to represent those games--
there's another
reason we did that,
but I'll get to
that in a moment--
there's Push-k-x
and Push-star-x.
OK.
Now let's talk about complexity.
That's the right
two columns here.
The reference and
the complexity.
So all of these
problems are NP-hard.
OK?
But there's this
issue-- are they in NP
or are they PSPACE-Complete?
Question.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
What did you say
a fixed block is?
PROFESSOR: A fixed block is a
block that cannot be pushed.
So it's just glued
to the ground.
AUDIENCE: So this is
just whether or not
there are some blocks
that are fixed.
PROFESSOR: Right.
In these problems, this
is a more general version
than this game.
Here, you allow some blocks
to be specified as fixed.
Here, everything is
potentially movable.
Although if you have
more than k in a row,
it's like a fixed block.
If you have a k plus
1 by k plus 1 block,
that's fixed, effectively.
But you have a
resolution issue that you
can't make tiny fixed
blocks in this model.
And in this model there are
no fixed blocks whatsoever.
But here you can specify
some of them are fixed.
A lot of versions.
AUDIENCE: So push-star
has a boundary?
Otherwise you could just--
PROFESSOR: Push-star does
live in a rectangular box.
Yeah.
That is the one.
AUDIENCE: Is it fixed?
PROFESSOR: You could think of
that as fixed blocks or not.
If nothing is fixed, then you
can just walk off to infinity.
Move all the blocks
away and then come back
and find your destination.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
So they're all NP-hard.
There's a few that are
known to be PSPACE-Complete.
Push-Push, with a fixed
strength, is PSPACE-Complete.
Or with fixed blocks, I think,
should also be PSPACE-Complete.
That's not written here.
But Push-Push-Star, all
we know is NP-hardness.
Push-k-f, where k is at least 2,
is known to be PSPACE-Complete.
But Push-1-f or Push-2,
without the f, are both open.
And the reason we
were interested
in a non-crossing path is that
forces the problem to be an NP.
Because then you know
the solution path
has polynomial length.
You can visit each
square at most once.
So the hard part
here was to prove
that it's still NP-hard,
even with non-crossing paths.
We won't try to
prove that today.
So those, we actually have
tight bounds of NP-complete.
And Sokoban-- there's a
relatively old result--
1998-- that it's
PSPACE-Complete.
OK.
Let's do some reductions.
So this first reduction
is amazingly cool.
It's by Michael Hoffman, 2000.
This is Push-star with
a rectangular box.
OK.
So you're here.
The outlined regions
are the blank space.
Everything else is
filled with a block.
But every block
is movable and you
can push arbitrarily strongly.
So this is going
to be variables.
You're going to make
some choices here.
These are the connections
between variables and clauses.
This is a bipartite
graph encoded
in binary in the obvious way.
There's variables
here, clauses here.
There's a hole exactly when that
literal appears in that clause.
OK?
There's actually two rows
per variable, the true
and the false.
And then there's this gadget
here to connect the things.
And then these are
the clauses where
we're going to check that
they were all set correctly.
So let's go through it.
This is the schematic
diagram of what I just said.
We're going to start here
in the variable block
and walk through each
of the variables.
Here's what the
variables look like.
You have two rows, the xi row
and the xi complement row.
That's another way
to write NOT xi.
And you're going to count,
how many times does xi
appear in any clauses?
In the positive
form, negative form.
That's called ni and ni bar.
And you're going to
measure out these lengths.
You can negate variables to
make sure that ni is always
bigger than ni bar.
So do that.
So in this case, ni is this
big, ni bar is this big.
Measure it out.
This is your blank space.
And what you're allowed--
what we will show you
you're allowed to do--
is either move up here
and move all the way
over here and then up.
Or to move here and all
the way over and then up.
And this star is so that the
one block that's here could fit.
And then you can
go over to this x.
In general, in these gadgets,
the x is your target.
x marks the spot.
All right?
For the gadget.
And then there's a
global x, which will
be at the end of the clauses.
So what does this do?
Well if you think about
this connection block--
this is the bipartite
graph encoded as a matrix--
the number of blank spaces
over here is exactly ni.
So this is why, after you
push ni steps or ni bar steps,
you'll have to stop.
Because there are no blank
spaces to the right of you.
Then the only thing
you can do is go up
because there are no
blank spaces below you.
So in general, these gadgets are
super tight because above you
there's nothing.
It's all blocks.
And below you and left
of you, it's all blocks.
There's nothing you can do.
You put the next
variable gadget here,
so then that remains true.
In your row, and
in your columns,
you're completely packed.
So the only choice you have
is to do this or to do this.
And you will fill the
row that you choose.
Exactly.
OK?
So that's the variable gadget.
AUDIENCE: What prevents
you from choosing both?
PROFESSOR: You
could choose both.
Or you could do a little bit
of one and then do the other.
That's true.
But as we'll see, that
only makes your life worse.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Good question.
So next, we enter
the bridge gadget,
which is these two pictures
and it looks like this.
This is basically a
locking mechanism.
So you start here--
I'll just tell you're
supposed to do.
You walk over through
this blank space,
then you push all of
these things down to here.
So this basically prevents
you from going back
to where you were.
So you push all that down.
And then you go over here
and you tunnel down--
so I think you're moving
these blocks over to here.
That's another kind of lock.
And then you're pushing
this stuff down to here.
And then you get there.
So when all is said and
done, this will be down here,
this will be down here,
this will be over here.
And so when you're
in the clause block--
again, you have full
rows to your left,
full columns above you.
So there's nothing-- you can't
go up and you can't go left.
That's the purpose
of this gadget--
is to connect this
thing to this thing.
If there was a teleporter,
it would be much easier.
We could just leave
these all filled.
But we want to get up to here,
but make sure this is all
filled at the end.
So that's the sole
purpose of this gadget.
OK.
Now a clause.
How do we do a clause again?
So you have-- there's
three spaces here
because this is 3SAT.
You can move down one here,
and then move over two.
These two blocks go here.
And then you can get to the x.
Or you can go down here
and over and get to the x.
Or you can go here
and down, over.
And this is possible if
there's a hole below you.
This is possible if
there's a hole below you,
and this is possible if
there's a hole below you.
These are aligned
with these things.
So with exact-- I
didn't quite align them,
but these three columns
are these three columns.
And if one of these
is unfilled, you'll
be able to get
from here to here.
If they're all
filled, you won't.
Because it will be full
columns all the way down.
So that's a clause gadget
because things were filled when
you chose that thing to be--
maybe I-- did I
get it backwards?
AUDIENCE: So you're really
choosing the opposite.
PROFESSOR: Right.
You're choosing the
thing to be not true
and leaving the other one
to be as true as possible
by not pushing it.
So it leaves the hole so
that later you can traverse--
AUDIENCE: So that's why you
wouldn't want to choose both.
PROFESSOR: Right.
If you chose both, that
would be like making them
both of them not
true, and so you
don't get any of the benefits.
OK?
That's Push-star.
Cool?
OK.
Let's do Push-Push-1 in 3D.
This is really easy.
This is almost like the
Super Mario Brothers proof.
So it's just old drawing style.
And we've drawn sort
of the dual graphs,
so these paths are
little width-1 tunnels
that you can walk down.
So you start up here and you can
either push this thing this way
or this way.
And so you're choosing which
way you'll be able to traverse.
Either you can go the true
way or the false way--
the opposite of wherever
you push that block.
And so that cuts off
one of the things.
Then that path is going to be
connected to all of the clauses
that it satisfies.
That that literal
choice satisfies.
Then there's this
gadget to prevent you
from wrapping around
to the other side.
Whichever one you come down, you
will block off the other path.
And then you do that again
for the next variable,
the next variable, and so on.
At the end of the
last variable, you
run through all the clauses.
So how do the clauses work?
Very simple.
If any of the literals
that satisfy the clause
were visitable, then you
could push this block over.
And then later, when
you visit the clause--
at the end, when
you visit the clause
and try to traverse it--
if there's nothing here
when you push this
block down, it
will go all the
way to the bottom
and you're trapped, never to get
to the finish line down here.
But if at least one of these was
in, then it will block this guy
and you can-- if that's
true for all the clauses--
then you can get
to the destination.
So these are just
clause checking.
And that's a very
straightforward 3SAT proof.
In fact, the previous
proof is based on this one.
And the next proof
is based on this one.
And the Nintendo proofs
are all based on this one.
This is sort of the prototype.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Do you have the
crossover gadget that--
PROFESSOR: So this is 3D.
AUDIENCE: Oh, oh.
PROFESSOR: So
there's no crossover.
But in 2D, we want
to get a crossover.
So here's how we do 2D.
And this will work for
both Push and Push-1--
Push and Push-Push.
The only place we're
using Push-Push
was this clause gadget, so let's
first get rid of that aspect.
So here's something
called a lock,
and you're going to have to
believe a little bit here.
Your goal, let's say,
is to get from a to b.
And this is what happens if you
try to go from a to b directly.
There isn't much that
you can move-- well,
you can maybe move i down,
j left, and like this, but--
yes.
You can move i down, j left, e
down, f left, b down, but not c
left, because d is in the way.
OK?
So you can't get from a to b.
But if you visit from u, and you
push this block out of the way,
then you'd come back
through a, then you can do--
AUDIENCE: Push them over.
PROFESSOR: You can
do these things.
Push them all over.
And then you have
room to push c over,
and then a can go all the
way down, and you're through.
So this unlocks the lock.
Then allowing a to
be traversal later.
AUDIENCE: And going
backwards from v
to u would lock it again?
PROFESSOR: No.
This is not a reversible gadget.
It only works once.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: You can't unlock.
Once l's down, it's
permanently there.
So now we're going to use
this in a clause as follows.
So here's the lock
and then there's
this schematic above it.
So we have three
possible entries.
This is xi or NOT xj or xk.
And we're going
to use this gadget
to say, well if you come
down the true path from here,
you're going to have to
push this block down,
which prevents you from using
the other half of the gadget.
So either you move
y or you move x.
From then on, you can only
do west to south traversal
or only north to east traversal.
So it blocks the other path.
So this is--
because I don't want
to come down here,
unlock the lock,
and then go back on
a different path.
Because that's not something
that's necessarily true.
So as you come
down one of these,
you force these gadgets to
be in a particular state that
will only let you come
back the way you came--
go back the way you came.
And then you can unlock
the lock and then
this just connects back.
OK?
Then later, when we're
checking the clauses--
when we come through
all the clauses
to make sure that they're true--
we're going to route those
from a to b, to a to b,
to a to b for all the locks.
And if they're all
unlocked, then we'll
be able to traverse
them, and otherwise, not.
That's the idea.
OK.
Then we have the
issue of a crossover,
if we want to go into 2D.
So we have-- here's a basic
crossover in the Push-1 model,
or Push-Push-1.
If we're going to go from north
to south, then we will go--
OK.
We can push this down.
But we won't be able
to go to the east then.
OK?
And we're not able
to go to the west
because if we push this
block, it gets stuck.
So we can go north to
south, that's fine.
And we can also go west to
east, by symmetry, essentially.
But you can't go from west
to north or west to south,
or any of the
other combinations.
This works as long as
you do one or the other.
Once you do west to east, you
can't even do north to south.
So that's why we call
it an XOR crossover.
It's not what we want.
But if we combine
things in this way,
we get a uni-directional
crossover.
This is one where--
I better check my notes--
you can do with one
of three things.
You can do north to
south, if you want.
And then you can
do west to east.
So you could just
Or you could do north to
south, then west to east.
Or you could just
do north to south.
Those are all possible here.
So when we do north to south,
we prevent this particular thing
from being traversed.
But we unlock this gate, which
later, when we go west to east,
will allow us to do it.
So we go here and then these
are called no-reverse gadgets.
So once you push this block
back, you can never go--
this gadget becomes
untraversible.
So you come here, you push
this, push that, push that,
and now you can never
use this gadget again.
So it's like a single-use thing.
So you can come here.
If you tried to
do that, you would
get stuck because
this is a lock and it
hasn't been unlocked yet.
So instead you've got to go over
here, go through this thing,
permanently destroy it, and
then unlock this gadget,
and then you exit.
So that was north
to south traversal.
We unlocked this gate and
we unlocked this gate.
So if you're coming
west to east,
it could be this has
been done or not.
So going west to east, maybe
you haven't visited this gadget.
Then you can just
go through here,
block off a later north to
south traversal, that's OK.
Then come over here and leave.
And if you try to go
here, nothing happens.
OK?
Or it could be this
has already been done--
north to south-- and then when
you're coming from the west,
this has been unlocked, and
so you can open this gate
and come through here.
This has already been used,
so you can't go that way.
So instead you use this one.
This has already been unlocked,
so you can get through.
And then you get out.
So with just a little
bit of checking,
those are the only
things you can do.
So when we have this diagram--
I think I have one here--
variables and clauses, and
you connect all the variables
to all the clauses
they're involved in-- this
is a slide from lecture one,
but it's the same outline.
You know the order in which
these crossings happen.
Because you know I'm going to
visit variable i before I visit
variable j greater than i.
So I know how to order--
and each of these paths
is really two paths,
one and then the other.
And so I know whether
I'm going to do north
to south before west to east.
If not, I'd transpose the
gadget and exchange north-south
with west-east.
And then I don't need
that they're both visited.
I don't know which ones
are going to be visited,
but I could do one or the other.
Or if I do both, I know one
will come before the other.
So that kind of crossover
gadget is enough
for Push-1 and Push-Push-1.
And it's exactly mimicking
what we did with Super Mario
Brothers, we just had a
different variable choice
and a different clause and a
different crossover gadget.
But other than that, it
was exactly the same.
The gadgets were different,
but the proof structure
was the same.
And that's our beginning
of 3SAT reductions.
We will do many more next class.